[Music]
so welcome everybody
it is super excited to see everyone over
here especially after NAB no one decided
to take a siesta and join us so welcome
thank you very much let me start by
introducing myself and my co-presenters
today my name is Amber tank allarakha I
am a product manager on the Google
compute engine team and I represent the
team that is responsible for making sure
Windows workloads work great on GCE with
me today I have Ben and Michael Ben is
the TL for Google's M&A infrastructure
service team and Michael is a senior
director at a prenda and he also leads
the special interest group that is
tasked with bringing Windows containers
to kubernetes so welcome everyone and
let's get the show started so here are
some cool head shots of us in case our
life so let's have a quick overview of
what we're gonna be talking about today
so we're gonna start with sharing why
customers want to choose GCP for
bringing their Windows workloads what
are some of the recent launches and I'll
talk a little bit about our Windows
Partner Program I'm then gonna dive into
some of the key its platform specific
improvements that we have launched some
best practices and then Ben is gonna
come up on stage and showcase how his
team uses some of those to manage the
Windows IT infrastructure for alphabet
companies and acquisitions on Google
cloud last but not the least we're gonna
talk about how you can use containers to
deploy and scale your windows-based
applications and Michael is going to
come and present all the great work that
the sig has been doing to get Windows
container support over the kubernetes
before we go into that I really want to
iterate on our mission as you saw Brian
Stevens the VP at Google cloud say that
Windows is a priority for us and our
team truly believes that our mission is
to deliver the best performance security
reliability for Windows users on our
platform
and we've been at work over the last
year we have over a dozen windows
specific launches and you can see some
of them over here our journey with
Windows started in 2014 when we released
the first beta for Windows server
support in 2015 we g8 Windows Server 20
2008 and 2012 and as you can see we've
added a ton more capabilities in the
last year sequels of or VSS integrated
PD snapshots cloud tools for visual
studios and PowerShell and sequel HEA
clustering support so we're going to go
in into a bunch of these in detail but
along with all this great platform
support we are also building an
ecosystem we have a great set of Windows
partners who are not only experts in
Windows but also on GCP that can help
you migrate your Windows workloads from
wherever they are on Prem Colo over to
GCP so please oh gee we announced this
today Brian
you probably heard Brian in his keynote
I urge you to go to cloud or google.com
slash windows slash partners and check
out our great partners so now let's
answer this question why bring windows
were closed to GCP I was talking to a
couple of folks and they were like yeah
we would like to hear more about that so
let's let's just dive in the first thing
is Google's infrastructure when you'd
bring your Windows workloads to GCP you
get all the inherent unique capabilities
of our infrastructure your traffic will
never leave google's privately-owned
fibre network even when you go between
data centers what this means for you is
that you get super low latencies a
consistent throughput fast VM boot up
times and auto scaling that just works
and this is one of main reasons why we
have a ton of gaming companies and
enterprise companies who really love
running windows were closed or GCP for
folks who like transparent maintenance
we have live migration your VMs can move
from different hosts without any impact
to your workload and if you're really
interested in running sequel server
workloads on us we give 40 ki ops on our
persistent disk storage at no extra cost
price price is always very important we
really strive to give a very simple and
intuitive pricing model if you see our
windows pricing it's four cents per core
per hour for all your vm types so if you
want to understand what your cost is
going to be is a very simple and easy
way to calculate it no hidden costs most
windows will close run 24 by 7 and at
the end of it you get a sustained use
discount which gives you up to a 30%
lower cost at the end of the month just
by running your workload steady state we
announce the committed use discount
project program today if you want to
look at longer term commitments for your
steady-state workloads we have that
option too
one of the biggest things that customers
love when they come to our platform is
the flexibility of custom VMs custom
vm's is a great example you don't really
need to be locked in into any predefined
VM right so think about if you're
running sequel server you don't need to
run it on a 16 core VM when you just
need 10 V CPUs and that is really
powerful especially for Windows because
not only are you getting the Machine
shape that you exactly want but you no
longer have to pay license cost for
those extra V CPUs as licensing is tied
to course so as we as we make progress
in getting machines which have higher
memory with lower CPUs you can take full
advantage of that now I talked about a
bunch of these which were vary across
the platform let's talk about some
Windows specific reasons to bring your
world close to GCP we support sequel
server and Windows Server images you
could run sequel server even before but
now we have introduced things support
for sequel server always-on availability
groups so you can have the same age a
configuration that you had on-premise on
GC even though VMs today we have things
like volume Shadow Copy Service which is
very critical for enterprise workloads
who want to backup their data discs in a
reliable manner without affecting their
workload we have tools
the interactive serial port access you
have tools for visual Studios power
shells all the dotnet developers in the
room have ample support to run to write
their asp.net or asp.net core
applications on our
platform in the in the same spirit of
flexibility customers ask me I have
existing license for sequel server can I
bring them on yes you can bring on your
existing years with Software Assurance
over to GC P and all these features and
wide range of Windows and sequel server
images that I mentioned are available to
build to you in the free trial so if
you're new to the platform you want to
give it a try
register in our free trial program and
you can try all of these for $300
credits 12 months so hopefully these are
some good reasons and our customers
really value of some of these when they
bring their applications to us now let's
talk about bringing your VMs to GCE a
lot of customers have existing VMs
on-premise that they want to bring over
to g c e and we have a great partnership
with cloud and your which will migrate
your windows VMs to GCE at no charge
could that be better we recommend that
you go into our UI on our cloud console
right next to creating an instance
you'll have a nice button there it says
import VM and you will be able to follow
a very simple process to bring over your
Windows VMs we have a full range of
planning and implementation partners so
really encourage you to go check out
cloud Google /my great for details or
come up and ask me questions so let's
say we don't want to migrate a VM I just
want to spend up a new VM what do we
support we have a really long list of
windows server images and sequel server
images that we support I'd like to point
out that we release support for Windows
Server 2016 last year and we did that
within a week of Microsoft giing their
new OS version and I'd like to point
that out because this really shows that
we are committed to making sure that
anything that is the latest technology
on Windows is available on our platform
too and it also points to the great
relationship that we have with Microsoft
in helping us doing this in a really
timely manner we have support for core
and nan-oh coming soon and a lot of
customers asked us for sequel server
images so these are images with the
licensing including you don't need a fly
you don't need to buy licensing anywhere
it is pay as you go for minute billing
now when we talk about sequel server the
very next question is do you have a
chaise support and as I mentioned yes we
do have support for high availability
using always-on availability groups now
this is very similar to what you would
probably have on-premise you can deploy
a multi node sequel cluster set up your
availability group listener joyna to
your ad domain and have it work just
like you had it working on premise
yesterday we did a great demonstration
of this and fail demonstrate failover if
you want to have if you want to go and
see that talk please look at the
recording for running sequel silver's
but one thing I'd really like to point
out is we have detailed guides and
scripts but setting up sequel EHA is not
an easy process
anyone who set up a sequel ajay before
yeah a few of you so you know that this
is a multi-step process a lot that a lot
of things can go wrong and just to get a
proof of concept expose a bunch of time
so what we've done is we've got a cloud
launcher template in one click you can
set up a multi node cluster for you in
your project and this is great if you
want to do a quick POC you want to test
failover just see how it works on the
platform so really encourage you to go
and try that out we talked about VSS the
reason I want to release stress on VSS
is what you get with VSS is application
consistent backups for your data desks
on sequel server without having to turn
out your VM now this is a service that
is supported by Windows Server and
applications like sequel server have
create native support for VSS writers
and this is really a great unique
capability on our platform that'll allow
you to have more reliable backup and
disaster recovery solutions so now we've
set up all our VMs we've deployed a
bunch of AJ configurations simple
question how do I access my DMS
so we you can have access your VMs using
RDP by default that is open but we've
also supported win RM for all our
windows and sequel server images so you
can really take advantage of running
HTTP win RM over HTTP and accessing your
VMs I also talked a little bit about
tools like once your instance is set up
how do you exactly know that it's set up
correctly so let me show you
some of the cool things you can do with
the interactive serial port access
control I'm going to call this ice pack
because interactive serial port access
control is real tongue twister so you'll
see me saying ice pack a bunch so that's
what it is
okay so switching over to my demo
machine as you can see I've just spun
off with simple Windows instance this is
based on the Windows Server 2016 image
and I'm gonna try to see if this
instance was set up correctly so I'm
gonna click on in and I'm gonna scroll
down and I see this view serial port and
I'm gonna click on it and it will show
me that the instance was set up
correctly
I have RDP set up correctly have an RM
configured I'm good to go
now let's see if I can really already
pee into this machine it's taking some
time longer than expected oh this seems
to be an error so it says that the
remote access server is not enabled or
the machine's not running so I can I can
definitely see that the machines running
I saw that RDP was configured on my
instance so what do I do now so we have
interacted we have icepack so I'm going
to connect to the serial port really
quickly and just to save some time while
this has decisions in and I'll switch
back I actually already logged in so
let's see if it reconnects
right I'm gonna punch in my password and
there you go if you are a business admin
you'll recognize this console you didn't
have to leave the web browser and you
have access to this now I can run things
like hey is this did it also lose
Internet connectivity is this actually
connected so I'm gonna see it seems to
be connected to the Internet
fine most of the problems that we see
with RDP not working is the Windows
Firewall
the rules are not enabled or it's just
not on so let's let's just do a quick
check on what the Windows Firewall
status is oh the Windows Firewall is off
no wonder our DP is not working so let's
go and restart that I think I made a
let's type that again apparently I can't
type today
there you go so the Windows Firewall has
started now let me see if that really
fixed that issue let me go up and really
from the browser try to already pee in
super-convenient there you go
someone messed up the Windows Firewall
that was me but this is just for demo
purposes so switching back to slides so
you can see that you know we have really
worked hard on making sure that you know
certain difficult problems are made
really super easy for you and that's the
advantage of her running windows were
closed on us so we had a quick demo
so now you've deployed these machines
but you're not gonna do this one machine
at a time you want to deploy this in a
scalable fashion and we have some great
tools with startup and shutdown scripts
that allow you to do this so I'm gonna
have been up on stage to demonstrate how
their team takes a code driven approach
to managed IT infrastructure for
alphabet companies who are running
Windows on Google Cloud
thanks to murder hi my name is Ben
Miller I work for gules mergers and
acquisitions infrastructure services
team and I'm here to talk to you about
our project gecko which is currently
managing Windows instances in Google
cloud so what is gecko gecko is code
driven managed IT infrastructure for
alphabet entities and acquisitions
alphabet entities are separate companies
and so they often don't have access to
Google corporate IT infrastructure
although gecko needs customer
environments excuse me although each
gecko customer needs an independent IT
infrastructure for a variety of reasons
we need a scalable solution for
management of those environments we
strive to achieve this through services
policies and standards that we can
define in code and deploy through
automation our customers don't want to
spend time and energy reinventing the
wheels themselves so they order their
wheels from us gecko environments
contain Linux and Windows workstations
excuse me instances and use Active
Directory for directory services we
provide cloud hosted infrastructure
services to gecko customers services
like Active Directory network
infrastructure and security services
central file-sharing disaster recovery
our goal is a scalable e managed
infrastructure services in per customer
deployments following shared best
practices and using a shared management
framework gecko achieves this in part by
automating the deployment and
configuration of per customer GCE
environments here's a very high-level
example of what one might look like a
typical gecko environment is comprised
of a customer specific GCE project
connected to the customer's on-site
network via cloud VPN typically the
project will span multiple geographic
regions for fault tolerance each yako
service is expressed in code that
defines well understood and well tested
behaviors this functional code does not
change from one customer to the next
each gecko customer environment is
defined in a customer specific
repository which contains structured
configuration
files certificates and other things that
are specific to that customer this
repository defines all aspects of the
customer environment from host level
configuration to configuration
parameters that specialize the behavior
of each gecko service this repository
links back to the main gecko source
where all of the functional code is
maintained this link can point to the
most recent version of the gecko code or
it can be pinned to a specific version
this simplifies maintenance and upgrades
as new versions of gecko and gecko
services can be rolled out over time the
separation between functional code in
gecko and customer configuration can be
seen from the beginning during the
instance build process gecko instances
are built using a function that we
defined in our gecko PowerShell module
the instance can be built simply by
referring to its name and all of the
necessary details to build that instance
will be extracted from the customer's
configuration now let me focus for a
moment on how Google compute engine has
simplified windows instance building and
configuration first let me call out the
Google Cloud PowerShell module the folks
in Google cloud have provided us with
some fantastic tools to manage GCE
resources using PowerShell I'll be using
commandlets from this module to
demonstrate how we build Windows
infrastructure now let's talk about the
build image the Windows Server image
provided by GCE is kept up to date for
you with the latest hot fixes so you
don't have to maintain that yourself
when you boot a windows image for the
first time in Google Cloud it boots into
the system figuration Pass and for those
of you who are less familiar with
sysprep what this means is that the
first time a Windows instance is spun up
in your project it runs a series of
specialization tasks that finalize the
Windows install GCE gives you several
options to inject custom scripts into
this process without rebuilding the
image and one of these options is to
leverage the GCE metadata service to
store an instant specific script that
will be executed during the specialized
pass and that's what we do note that
this is an addition to the startup and
shutdown scripts that you can
so defined in metadata that will run at
each startup and shutdown of the
instance Gekko uses sysprep specialized
as an opportunity to inject a very
simple script to bootstrap the gecko
build and configuration process
okay can we switch the demo computer
please
okay the code that you will see here is
representative of the process of the
Gecko project employees but it is of
course not exactly the same code that we
use in production here we have a short
script that will be used to build a
Windows instance what we've done here is
reference the current GCE Windows Server
2016 core image populate the appropriate
metadata with our bootstrap script and
call add GCE instance to create the new
machine this command that is part of the
Google Cloud PowerShell module as you
can see you can also add a start up and
or shutdown script at the same time when
you are creating the instance so while
this runs let me show you how instance
metadata becomes a suspect specialized
script using the get GCE instance
commandlets you can retrieve an object
that describes all of the attributes of
your GCE instances now here I've drilled
down specifically just to list the
instance metadata you can see that the
start up shutdown and sysprep
specialized keys have been populated
with the values we've provided when the
instance was first created when a
Windows instances first created the GCE
the GCE agent on that machine looks for
the sysprep specialized key in the GCP
metadata service and if it exists it
executes it this is a really low
friction way of customizing your windows
instance builds as the script executes
its output is mirrored to the instances
serial port you already saw some of that
in the roots as demonstration but I want
to show you how this works in PowerShell
you can observe the serial output of
your DCP instances by using the cloud
console or by using the get GCE instance
command lit you can see low level output
of the instance boot process as well as
other messages that are logged by the
GCE agent if I do a little bit of quick
filtering we should see just the output
of the scripts that we defined in
metadata
the output is truncated somewhat but you
can see what I've done there as a script
executes excuse me one more slide there
we go okay let's go back to the slides
please
so to recap using Google Cloud
PowerShell we were able to reference a
pre-built Windows Server core image
defined startup shut down and sysprep
specialized scripts and create a GCE
instance we were also able to monitor
the progress of the instances build
using serial output and we did all of
this from within PowerShell now for
gecko now that we have built an instance
how it be configured and managed in a
nutshell gecko uses customer
configuration files to drive PowerShell
desired state configuration how does
this work well each gecko environment
has a configuration master and DSC terms
this is called a pole server the config
master iterates over the list of all
gecko instances defined in the customer
config based on the roles and services
associated with each instance templates
are merged together to construct the
full configuration for the instance
within each configuration template our
DSC resources whose attributes are
populated using properties that are
stored also in the customer
configuration file the output of this
process is a compiled DSC configuration
for each instance which the pole server
will host and on a schedule managed
instances will pull their new
configuration and apply them they will
report back to the config master with
data on what changes were made and
whether or not the configuration was
applied successfully now this is not a
one-time operation managed instances
will continually reevaluate their
configuration and ensure that the
desired configuration is applied so our
instances have been built and configured
how do we make changes to a customer
environment our management pipeline is
driven by open source projects we use
Gerrit for get based code review and
Jenkins for continuous integration
Gekkos strives to be a management
framework with strong accountability for
changes so how do we achieve this first
a gecko admin submits a change for
review now this does not alter the
customer environment but it's a proposed
change this change could be anything
from a new DNS record to change to group
policy to firewall rules just to name a
few examples now this proposed change
needs approval from two sources first
our Jenkins instance will automatically
run unit and integration tests and
second another member of the gecko admin
team has to review the commits and
provide final approval now finally once
all this is done the configuration
Master will recompile instance
configurations based on the change and
the gecko instances will pick up those
changes now this management pipeline is
the core of gecko but why why did we
take this approach to systems
administration instead of managing
things in a more traditional fashion by
defining our architecture in code and
config we can have strong assurance that
the infrastructure is built and operates
as designed when we implement best
practices we were able to implement
across all of our customers and by
standardizing the services that we
deploy and the way in which we deploy
them we were able to manage many
customer environments using the same set
of management tools and procedures all
of this allows us to scale support for
additional customers without having to
also linearly scale the size of our team
but why do we choose to build gecko on
GCE well first of all we take a lot of
value from from GCE
specific support for Windows as a
platform custom instance sizing and
simple hosted windows licensing makes it
easy for us to predict and invoice costs
per customer building Windows VMs on GCE
is really fast and simple to automate
and Google Cloud PowerShell is a huge
win for us allowing us to automate GCE
using the same management framework that
we use to manage our Windows
infrastructure now finally as a customer
of Google cloud the single biggest win
is the performance stability and
security
of GCP it allows our team to focus on
just those challenges that are ours to
solve now let me hand the time back to
Ann Murgia who's going to talk about
container support for Windows workloads
Thank You Ben
so you saw a great time on station of
how you can configure configure Windows
infrastructure on GCE
the question I often get from customers
more recently is how do you deploy your
windows-based applications using
containers and the answer is there are
many different parts that you can take
on GCP you can stand up a Windows Server
VM Windows Server 2016 which is the
first version to support docker and
Windows Server containers and run your
Windows containers on that we also have
support for nano server which is coming
soon we should have a much smaller
footprint you can choose to have asp.net
core apps and run them in either Windows
Server containers or Linux containers
you have options when you want to manage
orchestration of your containers and you
can either choose kubernetes or Google
compute engine so today if you have an
asp.net core app you can run it on a Lux
container on Google container engine we
are also contributing to the open source
special interest group that I mentioned
which is tasked with bringing Windows
containers support to kubernetes and if
you want an even more managed solution
than you can we just launched support
for asp.net core on App Engine flex or
App Engine flexible environments so you
can have multiple different options now
in order to demonstrate the great work
that the open source community has been
doing for Windows containers and
kubernetes I'd like to call up Michael
on stage to talk more about that
Thank You Merida hi everybody so I'm
here representing the special interest
group for Windows Server containers from
the kubernetes community so quick show
of hands how many of you guys have used
kubernetes so far we're there on premise
or in a cloud provider like go cloud all
right a few of you guys so one of the
most important things is if you are
using kubernetes it is one of the best
tools out there to be able to it manage
deploy containers at scale it really
makes life simple so if you are
deploying containers today in
traditional virtual machines or or
whether that's on premise or in a cloud
provider it's hard to actually make sure
what image are you using control the
workflow whether that's continuous
integration or a continuous deployment
system and being able to scale those
with kubernetes you have a complete
platform the managers the end-to-end
lifecycle of your containers from the
point where you define what the
application you wanna run into the
container to defining the networking for
it being able to scale it to the
hundreds or thousands of nodes and then
being able to version that and go from
version one to version two and so on and
so forth so within the community which
has been running for a while now one
thing was lacking and that was Windows
Server support so the sig windows team
was tasked to go and bring Windows
server support the kubernetes and more
importantly to be able to run Windows
Server containers what that would give
us is one of the best cross-platform
heterogeneous cluster monitors and it
would allow us to expand the types of
applications that can run on kubernetes
so before you used to have applications
that were run on the Linux operating
system by introducing Windows Server
containers now you can run iis based
applications you can run dotnet core
applications you can run Windows
services in any other application that
can run on the Windows OS so that's a
tremendous amount of change introduced
to kubernetes now with the ability to
run all these extra workloads and all of
our work here in the special interest
group is
really based on top of the work the
Microsoft done to both introduce Windows
Server containers to the to the
operating system as well as a lot of the
networking enhancements that have been
made there's a few companies that I want
to call out here that have been doing a
lot of work in the in the group and
that's a prenda where I'm coming from
there's cloud base Google Microsoft and
in Red Hat as well all these guys are
contributing to make this a reality from
a from a status perspective we are have
alpha support in kubernetes today so you
can go and download our binaries and try
this out and with with the release of
kubernetes that will come towards the
end of q2 of this year we'll go embed uh
so let's take a look at the architecture
really quickly one of the things that we
wanted to make sure is that we kept the
simplicity of kubernetes and docker as
it exists today so on the left hand side
you have the existing dr architecture
for for Linux on kubernetes and you'll
see that you have the docker images the
engine and then you have a shirt kernel
down at the bottom where you can have
one or more containers running on top of
the same container host that's the
compute unit that's running your your
ecosystem and on the right side when we
start architecting things for the
windows side it was very advantageous
that docker now runs on Windows Server
and it has a very similar model to the
running Linux so we maintain the parity
of having the docker images on the node
you have your door engine demon which is
what we are talking to as kubernetes and
then having one or more containers
running on top of a shared kernel I
would like to point out that Windows
Server supports two types of containers
today one of it is Windows Server
containers where you have a shared
kernel and it also supports hyper-v
containers where you have kernel-mode
isolation as well right now we have been
predominantly working on Windows Server
containers but there's nothing that
prevents us from supporting hyper-v
containers as well as you go towards
better
with the alpha support that we had this
is what our architecture looked like so
you have the physical Internet coming up
from the top and then you have the
couplet and the ku proxy which are the
two components of kubernetes I kind of
drive the core functionality and then
you have an abstraction called a pod
which is the lowest unit of deployment
in kubernetes that can contain one or
more containers think of a pod as a
micro service for example that can be
implemented inside one or more
containers so with with the alpha
support this is what it would look like
and we went ahead and completely rewrote
the networking stack of kubernetes for
Windows Server containers as we march
towards better to her eliminate
completely the KU proxy and use ovn and
OVS as the networking backbone for our
containers this provided us a tremendous
amount of advantages and it allow us as
we move towards the future to support
things like network overlays and be able
to do a network namespace isolation for
containers that spans both Windows and
Linux so imagine this you'll be able to
have a single application that has
containers running on Linux and on
Windows both of them in a single network
namespace communicating with each other
in a secure and scalable manner so let's
switch here to a demo and show you some
of this work in real time and what
you're looking at here is the Google
Cloud SDK shell so all of our components
here are running in Google Cloud so I'm
going to go ahead and create an SSH
session to my kubernetes master
component so I will go ahead and change
the resolution here so you guys can see
that fairly well
all right so the first thing we're gonna
do is we're gonna go ahead and run as
administrator' here and we're gonna run
clip CTL this is the command-line
interface of kubernetes and i'm gonna go
ahead and get all the nodes that we have
in the system here and notice that I
have to know to have a master component
that's running on Linux and it contains
all of the core pieces to run kubernetes
and then the second thing I have is I
have a worker node that's running
Windows Server that is able to host pods
on Windows so if I check if I have any
pot here you'll notice that I don't have
any pots deployed right now so there's
no resources deployed in the system to
demonstrate here some of the
capabilities of our node let's go ahead
and describe the Windows node and notice
that you know it's a architectures amd64
it's running the same couplet and to
proxy version that the rest of my
kubernetes environment is running and it
has the same type of details in terms of
the CPU performance metrics memory
matrix and all other details like labels
the kubernetes has so if I run this
command here now I'll be able to show
you the labels that identifying each
node in my system so notice that my
master components running Linux with MD
64 architecture and now I have my worker
in Windows node that's running the
Windows operating system and it's
labeled accordingly and now this label
is important because that's how we're
gonna select hard to be attached to that
node so when you're deploying containers
and kubernetes you get to tell
kubernetes where would you like those to
be deployed think of leaders as a simple
deployment policy and we'll use the
labels that are identifying each one of
our nodes so so let's get started here
let's go ahead and deploy some
containers
so the first containers I'm gonna go
ahead and deploy is the first tier of my
application and this is a Redis cache
that will form the data part of my
application some application is going to
be a micro service that has three
components ready slave Redis master as
well as a guestbook Go application
running all of these components running
on Windows but there's nothing
preventing me from running one of them
on Linux if I so choose
so we went ahead and deployed the the
Redis master so I can go ahead and run
my my pod command again and now notice
that I have a single instance of my
Redis master running here so if I for my
command
keeps it here logs and point it to the
Redis master
notice that we have registry todo at
5:04 running inside windows so go ahead
and create the slave now that will
communicate with the master pod to
complete the second tier of our
application and one things I want to
show you is what does that look like so
let's go ahead and and look at one of
the Redis components here so this is a
deployment specification on kubernetes
so the pod that abstraction I mentioned
earlier is defined using a specification
like this so in this deployment
specification um and indicating that my
name is already slave and I want to use
this specific image from the docker hub
it's already slave 3 dodo nano server so
choosing the nano server OS and it's
basically exposing port 63 79 over TCP
and the last important thing here is the
fact that the node selector is targeting
Windows Server so now that we did this
if we if we exit out of the component
here and we run a pod command again
notice now that I have to slave ready
slave containers pods
I've been running and they have a very
distinct IP address for each one of them
and that's basically and they're all
running on Windows server now so if I go
back and check the logs for my master
notice now that the master was able to
communicate on with the slave at 460 379
and that's the same port that I
identified in my description or telling
it go ahead and find each other using
the port so now we have two tiers of our
application I've been running who have a
ready slave who have a Redis master they
have were able to find each other and
communicate and they're all running in
Windows so let's go ahead now and deploy
the last piece of our application which
is a guestbook application written in go
notice now that we created a single
instance of our guests food application
and I can actually go ahead and connect
it so I can run cube CTL exact - IT and
provide the guestbook note here and I'm
gonna run PowerShell so now we have a
partial execution inside the container
that's running our guestbook application
so I can run IP config here and I get an
IP address and that's the IP address of
my container and I can even actually
ping the outside world you might not
think this is much but it took us a long
time to be able to enable Internet
access inside a container using the AVI
and overlay network so I had to
introduce things like a gateway node and
be able to route the traffic create a
correct Interpol and inter container
connectivity so even though this is
simple and we all take Internet access
for granted this was a lot of work to
make that happen
so now we actually have our parts we
have the we have the service as well and
three different sets of pods that are
comprised this this specific service so
go ahead and describe or service in
kubernetes and there's a few details
here about our service that was taken
out of the specification you have a
guestbook application it has an IP
address it has a couple of different
ports that you can use to access it and
I can actually go ahead and run a
command here to against that application
and now go ahead and change the IP
address here
and notice that he returned back some
data telling me a your own container
1024 9.4 more importantly I can switch
over here to my Windows node that is the
Windows node that's the worker node
that's part of my cluster and notice
everything is running on GCP here I can
switch on this node and I can open up a
web browser and hit my guestbook
application I can enter some data here
and I'm gonna call it audience one two
and three so if I go back to my script
here and I run the crow command again
I'm getting back the data because I was
able to query that application so let's
go ahead and scale it and see some of
the advantages of kubernetes so I'm
gonna run a command here that
essentially is instructing kubernetes to
increase the deployment of guestbook to
a three replicas count so if I run my
cat pot command again I get to see that
guestbook now has three instances
running now all three instances are
gonna be load balanced by kubernetes so
as a developer I don't have to do
anything extra I can take advantage of
the complete backbone of kubernetes that
will handle routing load balancing fault
tolerance high availability and all I
had to do was deploy my application and
all of those things are taken for
granted and they're available to me to
use so now I can go back to my web
browser again and as i refresh I can see
the endpoints changing sometimes now
they're sticky sessions happening in the
web browser so you might not be able to
see it as clearly so I went ahead and
wrote a script here that will invoke the
URI from application 20 times and print
the contents and notice here that every
time we invoke it the IP address
sometimes changes because kubernetes is
basically load balancing the the request
to my application based on number of
requests per second so some of them are
hitting the container IP dot for one
to actually have a third one here as
well so if we go up we should be able to
see the 187 IP addresses walk here so
those are the three IP addresses that
are part of my pod that are available
for load balancing for my application
and if you go back to guestbook here if
I click the environment variables it is
clearly evident here that I'm running on
Windows this is Windows Server
containers I'm able to see all the
information about the Redis cache that
is part of my application and I can come
back into the node and I can run docker
commands like docker images and see the
images that I was able to use for the
diplom home application on docker PS and
look at all the containers that were
deployed by kubernetes as part of my app
so kubernetes handled everything from
the deployment containers they're
setting up of them they're working back
on the load balancing as well as making
sure that my containers are I've been
running and highly available let's go
ahead and switch to the slides
so we showed you how kubernetes and the
community is bringing Windows server
support into the into the entire
ecosystem or encouraging everybody if
you want to get involved or even try
this work go ahead and find us on slack
you can also visit our github page and
encourage everybody that's passionate
about Windows passionate about
orchestrators and cluster managers to
come along go ahead and get involved try
out our capabilities or create a PR and
introduce some of your own code into the
mix thank you wasn't that awesome
so we've taken you through this journey
and kind of told you some of the
capabilities of the platform some
reasons that we'll give you some really
great advantages by bringing windows
were close to us we have tools to bring
your traditional Windows workloads and
we have some great set of tools if you
want to modernize your Windows workloads
with kubernetes support with App Engine
flex and so and so forth so we have a
ton of resources at cloud at google.com
slash Windows sequel server slash dotnet
so really encourage you to kind of go
and do a deeper dives and now we can
open up for some questions so I have up
here before we go into questions some of
the talks now we were the last talk so
there were some 200 and 300 level deep
dives and our sessions sort of brought
it all together to give you a quick
summary but please look at the
recordings if you've missed any and
there's a meter export session going on
right now
I think you'll probably have a few have
an hour for that too so please attend
that too so with that hopefully we
answered some of your questions and if
not we're here I'd like to call Michael
been up on stage and also funk who is
the TL for windows up on stage to take
any of your questions
[Music]
you